trop deuxième cij a su soir c'est le
succès de nicolas sarkozy n'entend
deuxième sujet toujours plus haut dans
les sondages
selon le baromètre mensuel de ipsos le
point l'ancien chef de l'état qui était
favori de la droite grimpe à la 3e place
chez les électeurs macro nist il le
double grille au poteau le drian pour
cela alors l'heure du retour at elle
sonné on les écoute c'était le 30 juin
dernier
ma place n'est plus nette dans la vie
politique partisane et ce livre n'est
pas un livre politique
je n'ai pas de calendrier politique
alors je peux le dire jusqu'à la fin de
l'émission
vous pouvez me croire pas me croire ne
peut pas empêcher les gens et je lui en
suis très reconnaissant de cette
fidélité et de cette sincérité mais
aujourd'hui ma place n'est plus là et
n'est plus là définitivement
les choses ont changé depuis le 30 juin
qu'est-ce que je ne suis pas dans la
tête du président sarkozy est ce qu'il
faut qu'il revienne dans la vie
politique question complexe c'est
d'abord à lui d'y répondre
ce qu'on peut retenir de nicolas sarkozy
d'abord c'est un bilan pas toujours
flatteurs 10000 postes de policiers de
gendarmes supprimés
avec aujourd'hui encore des stigmates de
ces de ces suppressions de postes fameux
paquet fiscal à l'été 2007 on se
souvient qu on avait creusé le déficit
public la france avait été le seul pays
à le faire
juste avant de dire ça franchement c'est
la réalité pas honte
tout cela réalisé entre le paquet fiscal
500 millions d'euros sur une réforme la
série 5 milliards si si si et les lignes
en 2009 c'est la crise internationale
martèlent en vrai il ya des passes en
déboursant nom ne vous est pas dire vous
ne pouvez pas vraiment le déficit s'est
creusé à cause du paquet à loretteville
palier vous reprenez les petits l'époque
non reprenait d'ailleurs reprenez le
bilan qui avait tiré la ville a retiré
la cour décor l'histoire du quinquennat
sarkozy
il y avait eu la france avait été isolé
à ce moment là justement en creusant son
déficit savait pas participé
particulièrement de la crédibilité
auprès des partenaires
troisième sujet on a eu assez peu de
réformes structurelles ce dont on parle
et retraite à l'instant pas eu de
réforme structurelle le logement la
formation non plus bon il ya eu des
bonnes réformes également si on est
équilibré le programme d'investissement
juppé-rocard qui était aussi quand même
dans les dépenses y vit pas des grands
bon gp sur l'entente qu'a le programme
d'investissements d'avenir dans la
recherche dans l'innovation c'est
toujours des choses qui sont importantes
les incitations aux heures
supplémentaires qui étaient justement
dans le paquet fiscal ça on a fait
partie et puis enfin une autre réforme
dont on parle peu aujourd'hui parce
qu'elle est rentrée dans les moeurs mais
la qpc la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité en 2008 qui avait été
adoptée et compris avec une voix venue
de la gauche celle de jack lang qui
était à l'écran il ya un instant
donc il ya des points positifs des
points négatifs évidemment aujourd'hui
plus facile d'être populaire quand on
n'est plus au pouvoir
c'était le cas président mitterrand
celle quitté cas du président chirac
ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui c'est que
les sympathisants la république en
marche qui plébiscitent semble-t-il
nicolas sarkozy me semble-t-il
plébiscite d'abord l'image du
volontarisme en politique
pas forcément une ligne politique qui
d'ailleurs a beaucoup varié entre 2012
et entre 2005 on voit que dans ce
sondage également jean michel blanquer
qui a été intransigeant sur le sujet du
voile gagne 25 points donc c'est un
sondage qui semble conforter les
positions de fermeté a bonne entendeur
cette villa ce qu'est ce que vous en
pensez comment il faut lire ces chiffres
est-ce que alors est ce que c'est c'est
un appel au retour est ce que c'est un
livret que je pense pas qu'on compense
sur nicolas sarkozy il arriver à fédérer
une droite qui aujourd'hui apparaît
complètement de morceler à l'agonie et
nicolas sarkozy avait cette force est à
dire dans tes voilà de représenter une
espèce de synthèse à droite et puis et
puis de plérin un séducteur hors pair
quoi qu'on en pense un même les gens qui
étaient ces c'est assez incroyable de
voir ça même les gens qui étaient ses
opposant féroce rentrer dans son bureau
ressortez ait été séduit par le
personnage sait c'est vraiment une
grande force et c'est une espèce de 2
voilà deux personnages de romans et il
manque un petit peu ça aujourd'hui à
droite notamment
on se demande bien sûr bien sûr je dis
qu'il vaut deux langues mais bien sûr
bien sûr mais aujourd'hui on a du mal à
voir qui à droite pourrait lui succéder
dans l'état actuel des choses et c'est
un parti qui semble un petit peu
orphelins donc je sais pas si c'est par
des femmes il ya une forme je pense de
nostalgie et qui profite à ceux qui ne
sont plus maintenant à partir du moment
où
nicolas sarkozy explique ou laissent
entendre qu'il va revenir et ce sont des
rires c'est les juges qu'ils attendent
en fait et il le sait très bien et je
pense que ça en fait une espèce
d'impossibilité pour lui d'un retour
parce que il ya ces affaires judiciaires
qui continuent de le suivre
marc landré qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette n'étiez pas d'accord tout à
l'heure sur le bilan n'ont pas su bien
sûr le soleil la datation de la datation
le bouclier fiscal est on est on peut
être méchant j'ai pas vous comparez la
critique à la serpillière dakota nicolas
sarkozy est à côté je vous dit christian
jacob
aujourd'hui le lit dans la droite c'est
christian jacob est ce que christian
jacob fait rêver les foules
les grands mères les enfants n'ont rien
comme personne ne le connaît c'est ça il
peut pas incarner l'espoir où l'avenir
de la droite
donc forcément comme la nature a horreur
du vide et que nicolas sarkozy lui même
quand il n'est pas là naturellement il
s'impose ils sont il s'engouffre alors
après est ce qui reviendra à ce qu'il
faut qu'il revienne je dirais non
jusqu'à preuve du contraire
depuis qu'il a été balayée de la
présidentielle en 2012 en étant battu
par françois hollande c'est dire et
ensuite qui n'a pas pu se représenter en
2007 parce que les électeurs de la
droite l'omi troisième de la primaire
il se voit comme un recours possible et
si demain il y avait un problème dans la
république bas je suis le même déni oui
mais c'est jusqu'à preuve du contraire
vous savez dans la politique partisane
assez des mots en démon instances
partisanes qui continuent à envoyer ses
cartes postales à être présent à ce
qu'on parle de lui la preuve
mais moi ce qui me choque ce qui me
surprend le plus dans ce sondage c'est
parmi les personnalités avec du charisme
pour du poids que français il ya jack
lang il y avait quand même c'est quand
même dingue alors pas chez les
maquereaux nist je vous l'accordé il
n'est pas numéro 3 puisque c'est la
seule à regarder regardez personnalité
favorable de l'action helvetia jackon
numéro 2 38%
bon ce qui prouve que quand même les
françaises incapables d'avoir un peu de
de déraison et les notoires dont sarkozy
c'est qu'il a beaucoup monté par an
cette semaine il a pris six points wii
alors est ce qu'un sondage après la
valeur de bros wii puis la semaine
prochaine il va dire un mot il va
ressembler vas y vas t'on bison futé 2,5
donc en tout cas c'est sûr qu'il manque
à droite parce que comme le disait
rachel il ya personne
il ya christian jacob ce qui revient de
problème alors mathieu ce qui est plutôt
jacobs sarkozy rêvons d'un deuxième tour
nicolas sarkozy direct lors nicolas
nicolas
non le sondage n'est pas si surprenant
que cela en ce sens que questionne en
particulier les sympathisants de la
reine qui place effectivement nicolas
sarkozy est en deuxième position alors
très loin derrière emmanuel macron
succès c'est emmanuel macron partage
avec nicolas sarkozy une chose sa base
électorale est extrêmement solide
sarkozy avait fini très impopulaire mais
pas si impopulaire que son successeur ni
son prédécesseur parce qu'il avait
réussi à garder son noyau électoral de
façon très solide les électeurs de
droite étaient restés sarkozyste
quasiment jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat
de sarkozy
emmanuel macron à ça et il ne s'est pas
écroulé aux européennes en dépit d'une
année de gilet jaune parce que sa base
s'est resserrée au moment des
européennes
donc ils ont ça en commun et ils ont
autre chose en commun emmanuel macron en
2017 s'est fait élire avec les voix
d'hollande de 2012 pour lui dire
schématiquement en tout cas des voix de
centre gauche il sait il s'est maintenu
il sait ouais mais donc c'est plutôt le
centre gauche qui a fait de macron le
président de la république aux
européennes on a vu un cas d'école
absolument unique dont qu'ils soient
institutionnels française c'est la
droite qui happe qui a permis en fait à
emmanuel macron de maintenir son score
de la présidentielle
même score qu'à la présidentielle mais
pas du tout le même électorat et donc
c'est un électorat qui manifestement est
cohérent puisque c'est un électorat qui
aujourd'hui se reconnaît dans la
personne de nicolas sarkozy alors est ce
que nicolas sarkozy du coup incarne une
alternative
ben non puisque politiquement sans faire
injure ni à l'un ni à l'autre et il ya
même eu des bruits des bruits de
couloirs de nicolas sarkozy ou non de
son ancienne directrice de cabinet et
emmanuelle mignon
dix ans c'est le meilleur et maintenant
la crau est le meilleur président de
droite qu'on a eu depuis longtemps
ça prouve bien que en termes politiques
qui ont parlé du paquet fiscal tout à
l'heure les orientations économiques
fiscales en particulier de la macro ni
sont assez proches de ce que défendent
elles à sarkozy il ya une dizaine
d'années donc il ya une forme de
cohérence intellectuelle un recours
alors un recours ça supposerait
opération pardon n'est pas du tout 120
séminaires
non effectivement et de ce point de vue
là dire la base de
de la reine n'est pas du tout proche de
la base des républicains encore
aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy serait-il un
recours c'est dans des circonstances
politiques exceptionnelles
on n'a pas pensé à nicholas lui il ya
sans doute pensé mais on n'a pas pensé à
nicolas sarkozy l'année dernière en
pleine crise des gilets jaunes où on
s'est dit ah là pour une fois le pouvoir
est réellement fragilisé et par ailleurs
sur les grands sujets un peu lourd sur
lesquels le jeune âge des manuels macro
aurait pu peser comme une forme de de
faiblesse de fragilité je pense aux
grands sujets internationaux etc sur
lesquels au départ en tant qu homme
politique inexpérimenté on l'attendait
il s'est montré très crédible très vite
alors il n'a sans doute pas affronter
des situations internationales aussi
complexe que sarkozy avec la crise de
2008 sans doute même aussi complexe que
hollande avec le grec site etc
le la quasi chute de l'euro et voilà et
le terrorisme mais on peut dire que sur
ces sujets régaliens etc
en dépit de son jeune âge et de sa
faible expérience il est largement aussi
crédible que ne l'avait été un sarkozy à
dix ans donc pourquoi penser ce ryan et
ça se joue un retour en politique vous
qui connaissait bien ce milieu bien mais
c'est pas parce que ça ce jour il ya des
présidents qui ont cherché à revenir
sarkozy avait fait je crois que c'est
21% la primaire de la droite en 2016 ou
de ce point de vue là les choses sont
relativement trancher maintenant s'il
souhaite être candidat c'est son choix
jusqu'à ce n'est pas encore un paraît-il
cette barrière il pense encore c'est pas
à nous d'en décider simplement deux
points pour terminer là dessus pour ce
qui me concerne la droite va être
confronté à deux défis un premier défi
qui est la clarification de sa ligne
politique comme vous le disiez à
l'instant aujourd'hui la moitié des
électeurs de filles ont voté la reine
aux européennes donc qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire aujourd'hui les républicains
c'est une question qui lui est posée
deuxième question c'est celle de
l'incarnation ou city christian jacob
on aurait pu citer laurent wauquiez qui
avait représenté au début du quinquennat
macron potentiellement une espérance
pour ainsi qu'une certaine droite
aujourd'hui sortie relativement du jeu
parle de bar on parle de bertrand qui
sont sont dès aujourd'hui autour de 10%
c'est le score de l air aux européennes
en réalité donc tant qu'ils n'ont pas
tranché ces deux questions là se posera
la question de savoir dans quelle mesure
ils peuvent vraiment représenter une
force d'alternance alors d'internautes
qu'en pense-t-il babineau on dit même si
sarkozy garde une certaine bienveillance
d'une partie de la droite un retour en
politique est très faible
nicole dit à peu près la même chose à
prouver
ce commentaire spitz a new deal à droite
est moribonde et se dirige vers le même
destin que le ps sarkozy ferait mieux de
rejoindre macron ce serait logique
à chaque menace non logique non pas un
instant en tout cas je vois pas pourquoi
ils rejoindraient macron qu'est-ce qu'il
aurait à gagner pour quel moment un
ancien président ont rejoint un le
président non du tout il n'a aucun
intérêt même aucun intérêt faire alors
retour ou pas lui-même disait ce qu'il
disait en présentant son livre passion
souvent on m'a demandé si aujourd'hui la
politique me manquer invariablement je
réponds non
et je vois bien que peu nombreux sont
ceux qui le croient pourtant c'est la
vérité si l'on veut bien se donner la
peine de comprendre que ce n'est pas la
politique que j'aime c'est la vie à leur
suite au prochain numéro justement
l'inversé françois hollande vous évoquez
son livre reverser la loi c'est le
pakistan livre sauf erreur de ma part
j'ai lu dans la presse très dernière
montrait récemment qu'il s'était vendu à
270 milles exemplaires absolument
colossal autres de alors en poursuite
valérie pécresse
ok les mines en effet absolument ce qui
est quand même ainsi alors le livre est
excellent je le recommande pour de vrai
c'est un livre politique remarquable
mais 270 mille exemplaires aucun autre
président de la république n'était
parvenu à faire un tel score alors
pourtant sur twitter votre avis nicolas
sarkozy doit-il revenir en politique
oui 29% non 71% voilà malgré vos
recommandations
notre troisième su